et la vérité nous oblige à dire que
notre démarche
originalement était bien de s'assurer
que ce socle minimal demeura jusqu'au
terme des discussions sur cette loi la
vérité c'est que nous n'en sommes pas
sûrs et que notre démarche est encore
plus importante au commencement des
débat au Sénat qu'il y a quelques
semaines encore puisque rien que
finalement les propos du du gouvernement
nous laisse circonspect puisque
l'article 3 et je dire sa survivance
dépend des ministres
dépend des jours dépend des discussions
avec la droite et nous ne sommes pas en
réalité assurer que cet article 3 que
laame soit préservé je dois dire que on
pourrait peut-être même ajouter la
défense du droit du sol puisque il y a
également un certain nombre d'offensive
en en la matière c'est important de dire
que c'était un scle minimal sur lequel
nous sommes d'accord d'avoir une défense
qui soit une défense commune d'abord
parce parce qu'il nous s'agit de sortir
d'une hypocrisie considérable des pans
entiers de notre économie fonctionnent
parce que nous avons des travailleurs
étrangers des travailleurs qui sont
aussi sans papier certains d'entre eux
d'ailleurs mesurai quand même bien
l'hypocrisie de la situation payent des
cotisations social mais nonont pas de
titre de séjour donc ne peuvent pas se
loger et en réalité s'intégrer
pleinement or la force de l'intégration
par le travail nous paraît évidemment
indiscutable et nous le rappelons à
toutes cell tous ceux qui ont la valeur
travail en permanence à la bouche et
bien clantienne beaucoup de travailleurs
étrangers sans papier souhaite
travailler dans les meilleures dans les
meilleures conditions donc la bataille
n'est pas terminée la vigilance ne doit
pas
s'émousser parce que la réalité c'est
que au moment où nous parlons sur
l'ensemble de ce texte nous avons un
gouvernement qui
vraisemblablement n'a pas de majorité
euh et il est prêt à des concessions qui
sont en réalité les concessions sur les
principes qui nous fondent comme
République et comme et comme État de
droit je crois que c'est attaché à la
République à l'état de droit convaincu
de la force en réalité d'universalité de
nos valeurs que nous avons pu nous
retrouver sur cette question de la
défense de la me de la défense de
l'intégration et de la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papier ça n'est
pas une lubi c'est la position très
majoritaire de beaucoup de Françaises et
de Français qui sont interrogés
de semaine en semaine sur ce sujet